[Music]
foreign
you're watching the Press preview of
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive here at the Sky News
Center time to see what's making the
headlines with the associate editor of
the Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire and the
Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine very
good evening to you both thank you so
much for standing by waiting for us
they'll be with us uh with with us just
a few minutes time right up until
midnight tonight so let's have a look
what's on some of those front pages for
you starting with the telegraph it leads
with a report that Matt Hancock mounted
a rear guard action to close schools
earlier in the pandemic despite the then
education secretary Gavin Williamson
fighting to keep them open the guardian
also leads on the former Health
secretary writing that ministers are
battling to maintain confidence in the
official covert inquiry because of those
leaked messages the Metro also leads
with reaction to allegations that Matt
Hancock ignored care home test advice
during the pandemic the financial times
tomorrow reports that the bank of
England Governor Andrew Bailey signaled
to markets or that they are wrong to
assume that the bank will raise interest
rates any further and the eye reports on
bird flu and the possibility of
vaccinating UK chickens to stop bird flu
spreading to humans
where off is the headline on the sun
with the report the paper reporting on
the news that the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex have been asked to vacate
Frogmore Cottage in Windsor and the
express is also leading on that story
too quick reminder for you that by
scanning the QR code so you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch with us and of course we
hope you do so let's get now to our
fantastic guest tonight the associate
editor of the Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire
and the Daily Mail colonist Sarah Vine
both of course our regulars on this
program it is great to see you again
thank you so much for giving up your
Wednesday night to talk to us let's
start then with the day Telegraph why
not
um more bad news it seems for Matt
Hancock and indeed others regarding this
story uh let's start with you Sarah what
do you make of it tell us more
well it's quite interesting it's quite a
controversial Story I mean what the
telegraph has done a lot of people in my
industry think it's really underhand
actually
um because you know these these messages
were given to Isabel Oak short in good
faith as part of her job which was uh
ghost writing Matt Hancock's book and
she's decided to use them uh to preempt
the inquiry and of course you know
they're fascinating of course in their
detail but they do present a very
one-sided uh picture and and I'm not you
know I I'm not I don't think it's very
irresponsible journalism to be honest
why don't you think it's responsible
journalism
well because the inquiry will inevitably
go through all of these things
um but what by doing it this way what
they've done is effectively preempted
the whole inquiry undermined the inquiry
I mean their excuse is oh well you know
they might not come out but the thing is
is everything has to be seen in context
you know and I have to say that I was I
was sort of in the room on some of these
conversations not on the WhatsApp but I
was you know I was living with my
ex-husband Michael Gove at the time that
all these decisions were being made and
you know they were being made with the
utmost care and essentially it's
interesting that Gavin Williamson has
written in the telegraph today about the
uh question of of him arguing to keep
schools open and I remember having a
conversation with him in which he was
desperately trying to keep schools open
but the point is these things all need
to be seen in the context and if you
just take them out of the context in
which the messages were sent and you
only showed part of the picture you're
not really doing your job properly which
as a journalist is to tell the truth you
filling a part of the truth there's no
doubt about it but you have to tell the
old truth and that's my concern Okay
Kevin let's bring you in now let's pick
on that in a few few minutes time in
terms of Sarah's last comment then but
let's just run through the the kind of
the allegation shall we this of course
day two of more Revelations regarding
these leaked WhatsApp messages that
Sarah was telling us about
um what are they alleging in this case
tomorrow's paper Kevin yeah actually in
this case Hancock comes out on the The
Winning Side there is a December 2020
Boris Johnson is reluctant to look down
again as the number of cases and deaths
are going up and there was an argument
whether or not a schools should remain
open in December 2020 Gavin Williamson
the education secretary saying they they
should have remember him threatening
legal action against schools if they
should but Matt Hancock is arguing no
they will increase transmission
and when he lost the battle in December
2020 he said look another U-turn is it
in the making and what happened schools
met for a day reopened in England for a
day in the January then they shut until
March by and large you know they were
there were exceptions for instance you
know the children of key workers and so
on so Hancock came out on the right side
um so I
I disagree with Sarah and I think this
is in the public interest that we see
all this information in real time we're
seeing the battles that were in real
real time and we know more tonight than
we did last night and I think that's a
good thing when this inquiry could take
years it could be well after the next
general election before we get a full
report so yeah there's lots of questions
around
um Isabella oakshop releasing them She's
accused of stabbing Hancock in the back
by revealing them after she was giving
them for a book which she put her name
to as well as Hancock and she said in
the in the book it was telling the truth
well it's certainly not telling the
whole truth we can see that now and yes
she signed an NDA a non-disclosure
agreement a gagging order but I'm
personally pleased she's she she's
broken that because I think we do get
more information and you can ask hanko
what was he doing given all these
WhatsApp messages more than a hundred
thousand some with Boris Johnson
somewhere with Rishi suda we're gonna
hopefully get a lot of this from the
telegraph which handle the expenses
Scandal brilliantly when it used
checkbook journalism to buy a disk and
information back in uh in 2009 they've
got a team on this for two months so all
this week certainly will get bits
um yeah you can say what was he doing
giving all this information to a
journalist who was an outspoken critic
of lockdowns somebody who would have was
on the wrong or the different uh the
opposite side of the argument to him so
yeah he's judgment is certainly flawed
there and the book that was intended to
relaunch his career so the four thousand
copies the pandemic dies that was all
it's probably going to sink it because
people aren't going to be laughing at
him now when he goes on reality shows
after they know for instance the
railover Care Homes which he disputed
nevertheless but I I do think yep
journalistic uh ethics I I get that and
Isabella has to answer questions but I
think we as the public know know more
now than we did before and that's got to
be a good thing
um I should have to say before we move
on any further we have heard from a
spokesperson should say from Hancock
saying tonight's Revelations well these
are the relevation revelations in
tomorrow's paper are exactly like last
night's these are partial accounts that
obviously spun with agenda they show
Matt was focused throughout on saving
lives the right places for a full
assessment in the inquiry we've also
heard from Sir Gavin Williams and he of
course was the then education secretary
apparently he accused teachers of
looking for an excuse not to work during
the covert pandemic that's further down
into the article it seems he has tweeted
saying further to reports in the
Telegraph and other outlets I wish to
clarify that these messages are about
some unions and not teachers I was
responding regarding unions I had the
utmost respect for teachers who work
tirelessly to support students um we'll
leave that there and let's let's just
get your um your opinion Sarah on the
Metro I mean they've taken this story
but they're focusing on today's angle
saying they're sickened by Hancock's
messages grieving families reacted
angrily to claims that Matt Hancock
overalled experts advice to give a
covert test to anyone entering Care
Homes at the start of their pandemic
what do you make of their position
well again I think you need to see it in
the context of the time at the time
there weren't enough tests
um they simply didn't have enough tests
I mean there was a massive shortage and
they were you know they were they were
trying to make decisions almost
completely in the dark you can see how a
grieving family reading this would just
be second would be infuriated by this
yes but then on the other hand you see I
think they would need to see the full
picture unless this is my problem is I
don't think we're getting the full
picture and I think it's cruel
on the families of people who died to
give them glimpses of the process I
think the whole process needs to be seen
um because you know this is this is what
the what what the telegraph are doing is
is politicizing this awful situation and
they are using it to sell newspapers and
I have to say I disagree with
um Kevin I love you Kevin but I disagree
with you on the expenses thing because I
was involved in that and the telegraph
told things said things about me and my
husband at the time that were just
simply inaccurate despite the fact that
they had the correct information they
simply didn't want they ignored it
because it didn't suit their agenda and
I think this is really important here
because newspapers have a responsibility
you know we you know we have to
safeguard our our Free Speech it's a
very important thing we mustn't abuse it
and I'm not sure that this doesn't Edge
into that area that's my concern and I I
think it must be awful if you lost
somebody in the pandemic to be made to
feel that it was a deliberate attempt by
a health secretary to kill your relative
of course it wasn't of course that
wasn't what happened that's an absurd
suggestion and that's what we're that's
what's happening here and that's what
releasing these messages without any
context or attempt really to put the
other side is doing it's but Sarah and I
I agree look I don't think anybody
intended to intentionally kill anybody
but some people may are unintentionally
died because of decisions but I think
it's quite demonstrably true now that
the health secretary did not put a
protective ring around Care Homes we can
see that and when he would say he was
um following the signs he wasn't always
doing that political decisions were made
and I accept they're made in they're
made in real time in difficult
circumstances and the the pandemic
started of course there's not enough PPE
my Hong Kong did say there were no
shortages which was I think was also
incorrect as just so many people working
in the Health Service and elsewhere
would would testify and he tried to sell
a certain story and you you're quite
right we've got to be wary of how the
telegraph which has increasingly been
moving into a lockdown skeptic position
as a paper and looking back becoming far
more critical but Hancock with Isabella
Oak shock who is now accused of stabbing
him in the back produced his own very
partial Diaries the pandemic Diaries to
give his very partial partisan views and
Kevin just briefly because I want to
have you started it I just want to have
a quick look at the guardian before we
go to our break that they take an
interesting angle actually in tomorrow's
front page confidence in covert inquiry
is hit after the leak of Hancock
messages of course what she sent out
today defending the official inquiries
the right way to go but do you think
question marks now how now hang over
this inquiry
yeah if in fact the leak may make the
inquiry better in the sense that it
could speed it uh it could speed it up I
mean that is the problem it was really
set up not to report before the general
election that was the idea when Boris
Johnson was in power when he was prime
minister when he was in Downing Street
because of party game not because of
just because of his decisions at the
time but because he was very compromised
by breaking covert rules and of course
he got that he got that fine but yeah
confidence in the inquiry is dented but
I think I think if we won back that
better Hancock says he's given all the
evidence to the inquiry if I was them I
would be checking the WhatsApp messages
they got against the telegraphs just to
make sure it's gonna be out it's gonna
be a big story tomorrow we've got plenty
more papers to get through Sarah and
Kevin for now thank you very much more
reaction to the news that Harry and
Megan have been asked to leave Frogmore
Cottage is coming up after this special
break the cinema
thank you
[Music]
hi there welcome back you're watching
the Press preview back with me now is
the associate editor of the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire we're also joined tonight
by The Daily Mail Economist Sarah Vine
welcome back to you both again thank you
for your time this evening let's have a
look at some of the other papers making
a headlines uh tomorrow morning and the
I newspaper says UK chickens maybe get
maybe given Jabs to stop bird flu spread
in humans the government considers
vaccinating UK poultry flocks against
bird flu to fight the worst ever Global
outbreak and prevent future pandemic in
humans uh we're finished with Kevin so
Sarah let's start with you what do you
make of this front page
it seems like a perfectly sensible idea
I mean you know we inject humans against
flu why not inject chickens I you know I
don't really know what to say it's not
really a very interesting splash
well it would be in Monumental task
wouldn't it I mean we know that there
are a lot of chickens you're right it
would be quite a lot of chickens I mean
I suppose the fact that it's causing
absolute Carnage is in the poultry
industry but of course Kevin on a much
more serious note as well you know the
risk of transmitting between mammals and
of course the risk to humans and we know
what's happened to that girl in Cambodia
I mean the threat potentially is real
isn't it
yeah it may be small but if it's it's
real just deal with it although I can
imagine me a hell of a flap trying to uh
inject uh what millions and millions of
birds uh you know perhaps the uh you
know they can go I think there's some
evidence it can go from you know flocks
that are kept on farms into into the
wildlife and then to jump into people
that that is worrying so I know it does
just seem sensible but Is it feasible
that's that's what I wonder is it is it
actually physically possible and is it
economically viable yep good question
onto the front page of oh did you want
to come in Sarah well I was just going
to say is maybe if we kept our chicken
slightly better and didn't treat them
free range is the way forward isn't it
onto the front page of the daily mail um
and a really powerful story actually
from Carrie Johnson uh Carey says keep
killer pilot behind bars so Sarah tell
us more
this is a horrible story this man uh
killed his estranged wife with a claw
hammer in front of that well not in
front of the same house as their two
small children
um having having dug her grave uh in US
in in Windsor Great Park actually and uh
and sort of you know equipped himself
with a plastic box to put her body in
and for some reason he was only
convicted of manslaughter which just
seems extraordinary anyway he's done 13
years and the suggestion is is that he
could be out on parole and Carrie
Johnson who
um some people may not remember or know
was instrumental in keeping uh War boys
who was the black cab rapist who is
thought to have attacks you know upwards
of 100 women
um keeping him behind bars
um by giving testimony so she's taken up
this cause um which I think is a is a
very good one because quite honestly 13
years for beating your wife to death
with clawhammer is an insult it's not
just as in any shape or form yeah Kevin
what do you make of her intervention of
obviously she's very high profile isn't
she in this country and many people may
not realize her own backstory her own
personal backstory to this
no that's right so um I mentioned there
John wallboy is the black Cabaret was
because when she was 19 she was drunk by
him uh and uh clearly had an effect on
her um and John Moore boys could have
been released early uh if she and others
hadn't forced the Justice secretary and
intervene and I think she's she's right
on this and a lot of women are many men
too and to cross party in Westminster
this guy Robert Brown it was
manslaughter with diminished
responsibility so he served 13 of a 26
year
sentence but it given the Barbara
Barbara tree and the savageness of the
the murder it just it just doesn't feel
like justice I I agree you know
his uh his dead former wife um is IT
Joanna Joanna's uh mother was at the
meeting in Westminster too and it it
just Beggars belief now I I believe in
Rehabilitation and Redemption and
sometimes think the wrong people are in
prison when they have problems with
literacy and alcohol and other problems
but there are some serious people who
commit a terrible who shall be behind
bars including this guy
quick look before we go on the front of
the Sun newspaper eviction notice that
says Dear tenants Harry and Megan you're
hereby giving an eviction notice to
vacate Frogmore Cottage immediately
after one's coronation in May the
headline reading we're off I hope I said
that properly Sarah we've got about
we've got about we've got about actually
we haven't even got 10 seconds to talk
to you tell you what we're going to talk
about it it's the tiniest violin it's
the tiniest violin ever the tires violin
Sarah says we are going to talk about it
in the 11 o'clock you don't go anywhere
and we'll talk about that properly
shortly thank you for now